what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
all right so as we get to the conclusion
of spider-man Clone Saga one of the
questions that I've seen in the comments
is why didn't we cover the whole thing
alright here's the reason why we didn't
cover the whole thing here's a really
good example there's a point in the
story where Gwen Stacy comes back and we
learn that the gwen stacy we see in the
story is a clone pretending to be a
woman pretending to be a clone that's
just one example and there's a multitude
of others for example between the story
crossfire I think it was a dealt with
this guy Judas traveler who could cast
illusions I had nothing to do with clone
saga but between that story and the
trial of Peter Parker the last video
that we did about three months past in
the sense that the trial of Peter Parker
was released three months after it was
originally supposed to hit basically
fell behind by about three months or so
because of that what Marvel did is they
went through and they basically just
flooded the entire spider-man landscape
with nothing but like one shots and
miniseries they were just giving us
stories but had almost nothing to do
with the Clone Saga or if they did
associate with the Clone Saga they
didn't move the story in any direction
it was literally just filling time and
so because of that if I were to go
through and make those videos one I
would get lost I would get confused I'd
have to go back and we'd probably end up
seeing delays in the videos and between
all the Declaration of retcons and
changes all I kind of get stuff it would
confuse me and it would probably confuse
you and you probably get frustrated and
just stop watching the video but one of
the big revelations that came with all
this was the fact that where previously
it was believed that the jackal was the
one who was behind all the events of a
Clone Saga the jackal was the one who
had made Ben Riley the jackal was the
one who had maintained the jackal was
the one that sent all these events in
motion and all that kind of good stuff
what ended up happening is Marvel
basically came back and said no that's
not true
everything we've told you was a lie and
that's why fans got so bent out of shape
and why they got so angry is because
just when they thought they were
beginning to get a grasp on this
insanely convoluted story
well then suddenly Marvel came along and
said no that's actually not true at all
instead the real mastermind behind the
entire events of the Clone Saga is none
other than Norman Osborn
now this was kind of cool but it was
also kind of weird I personally thought
it was interesting the Norman Osborn had
made a return and the way that this was
done the way his return was written was
actually kind of interesting I mean
there are those who just hated this they
absolutely despised it but there were
some like me who didn't really think it
was that bad but with regards to - you
know Norman Osborn this is the first
time he comes back in Marvel Comics
following his death at the hands of
Peter Parker
after the night when Stacey died Norman
Osborn had basically died in amazing
spider-man issues 121 and 122 during the
fight between himself and Peter Parker
after the death of Gwen Stacy the story
was really kind of leading up to the
death of the Green Goblin the biggest
problem that Marvel had though was that
the Green Goblin was huge in terms of
popularity it was absolutely net and so
because of that Marvel had to eventually
bring him back or they had to bring back
the Green Goblin concept and some former
fashion now what this story does is it
actually invokes a lot of that stuff but
it tells us what it was that Norman
Osborn was doing behind the scenes what
we know is that again because he would
basically just kind of resurrected or at
least he had just come back to life is
because the goblin goblin formula in his
veins that basically allowed his body to
heal which allowed him to come back
instead of just immediately popping up
on the scene and just saying I'm Norman
Osborn and going back and attacking
Peter Parker again instead because of
the fact of the death of Gwen Stacy had
unhinged Peter Parker to a degree I mean
didn't make him crazy but because it had
unhinged into a degree the goal of
Osborn was to basically take away
everything that Peter Parker cared about
and so what he ended up doing was
basically operating behind the scenes
and building an empire of sorts for
himself now one of the other reasons why
it was that Osborn didn't intervene at
least the indications given here is
because of the fact that his son Harry
Osborn had taken up the mantle of Green
Goblin again that was something that had
already been written and so really
because this has already been
established because it was an intrinsic
part of the spider-man mythos Marvel
couldn't go back and change it right
like that's the nature of a retcon in a
lot of different ways suppose you guys
who are new to comic books a retcon
stands for retroactive continuity and
what that means is that there are you
know concrete pillars in the realm of
Marvel Comics for example Captain
America Steve Rogers or I guess the guy
Steve Rogers received an injection they
gave him the Super Soldier Serum which
led to him becoming Captain America
Peter Parker was bitten by a radioactive
spider those are things that do not
change the motivation for why those
happened have changed from time to time
and that's how a retcon works for
example you know with regards to Captain
America
it was previously believed that there
was just a guy
Abraham Erskine that injected him with a
Super Soldier Serum and he became
Captain America
done and done it was simple as that it
wasn't until years later that we learned
he was the first in a long line of
people that were part of weapons plus he
was weapon one which went all the way up
to Weapon X or weapon ten that led to
Wolverine so that's what I'm talking
about when I say retroactive continuity
the idea of Harry Osborn having donned
the Green Goblin costume and becoming
the second Green Goblin
that's something this is unshakeable
that's concrete you can't get rid of
that in the spider-man landscape this is
because it's so intrinsic to Peter
Parker himself and his relationship to
Harry Osborn and so instead of changing
that Marvel had to work around that and
just say well you know Norman Osborn was
just in the background watching all
these events unfold and it's like that
with virtually everything that goes on
when it comes to Phil Urich being the
next iteration of the Green Goblin and
then going on to become the Hobgoblin
Marvel couldn't change those because
they're concrete aspects of the
spider-man mythos and so instead when it
came to Oz born they had to simply work
around it by having him just watch all
these events unfold now what onward had
done is while he was in the background
again because he was forming an empire
what he needed were resources he needed
a vast network of information as the
what he did is he actually joined a
group called the Brotherhood of the
screws now the Brotherhood of the
squares is a cabal that's been around
for God forever and ever and ever and
ever and they really just kind of like
worship this cosmic entity so to speak
play one of these elder gods that it's
supposedly been around for decades it's
one of those instances where Marvel you
know kind of brings in like a role
really like a cabal or like a cult of
sorts and says this cop worships a
particular God and this God is a God
that we just made up but he's been
around for a few million years or
billions of years or whatever it's just
one of those things they interject in a
story just for the sake of giving this
group a particular basis but the fact
remains that be part of the brotherhood
of the spheres meant that was Norman
Osborn because the squares care only
about money and power and accumulating
it in any means necessary it basically
gave Norman Osborn access to a vast
array of money and resources that he
wouldn't normally have and so what he
was able to do is while he wasn't in New
York itself he was basically operating
out of Europe it allowed him to use his
network to keep tabs on everything that
was going on and what this did is it led
to Osborn learning that The Jackal miles
horn was creating clones that after the
death of Gwen Stacy and you know the I
guess you know Peter Parker kind of
defeating Norman Osborn that miles
Warren who was in love with when Stacy
chose to get his revenge on Peter Parker
by cloning Gwen Stacy and cloning Peter
himself and this is when the whole basis
of the idea of Cain and Ben Riley and
all that stuff begins to come into play
because what ended up happening here is
that where miles Warren basically
dispatched one of his guys you know one
of his career agents to go meddle with
things and to keep an eye on things we
found out this happened in two forms the
first was in the form of Mars Warren
himself and the second was Seward
trainer because of the fact that miles
Warren was creating these clones while
Osborn didn't really ally himself with
up with Miles Warren what he did do is
he looked at his views and said I can
use the work that Miles Warren's trying
to achieve for my own goals somewhere
later on down the line
and so Squier basically showed up and
said I will help you achieve what it is
that you want to do I will not tell you
who I'm working for
and I will not tell you why but I will
help you achieve this goal and Myles
warned the jackal just accepted that aid
because in truth you really kind of
needed it at the same time Seward
trainer was a guy who was basically
working for the jackal now again in our
last video we had covered Seward trainer
is simply saying that Seward was a
longtime friend of Ben Riley he was
really intelligent when it came to
genetics and of course he's a guy that
you know was the one that made the
revelation made the statement that Peter
Parker's the clone and Ben Riley's the
original the reason for that is because
the fact that this Square had shown up
to to Seward trainer while he was trying
to steal information from the jackal and
said I will keep your secret I will not
tell the jackal that you're trying to
steal his uh his documents at his notes
so you can pot it off as your own and
instead you know I will come to you at
some point along the line and I will ask
a favor and so in the background of all
this stuff with the help of the square
miles Warren created Cain as the first
clone came suffered from cellular
degeneration and was basically discarded
by Miles Warren this led to miles Warren
trying again and then eventually
creating Ben Riley and Gwen Stacy now of
course this led into the very first time
that then Riley in Peter Parker fought
one another which we saw in the events
of the original amazing spider-man Clone
Saga story in spider-man 149 150 and 151
I think it was now because
so after that this conflict had
eventually led to the idea of Peter
Parker defeating Ben Riley again Peter
looked at the clone and said if anybody
becomes aware of the fact that this
clone is here and they unmasked it
they'll look at this clone face and
realize that spider-man is Peter Parker
my identity will be out there in the
world and so Peter had basically taken
the body of the clone dumped it down a
smokestack
and walked away what we found out was
that miles Warren had basically taken
this clone out of the smokestack and
then replaced it with a clone skeleton
and then just sort of sit Ben Riley
along the way messing with its mind a
little bit now again miles Warren didn't
do this because Norman Osborn told him
to Norman Osborn was just watching all
these events unfold from the background
instead miles Warren was doing all of
this others on a court but what it did
afford him to do is the chance to
basically look at this and say I can
grab this corpse somewhere along the
line if I want to and use it for my own
ends but the whole idea of Osborn was
looking at the character of Ben Riley
and the reason for this was because his
home even though it wasn't really part
of his name plan his hope was that with
Ben Riley basically revealing to Peter
Parker that he was alive that that Riley
himself was alive and that Riley was
basically a clone of Peter ah that
intended to be there that it would
unhinge Peter in his entirety and it
would basically send his entire life
into a tailspin possibly driving insane
and he'd be institutionalized or any
number of things that would lead to his
life going into complete and total
disarray the problem with this is that
as we know that didn't happen instead
what basically took place was that Peter
himself ended up bonding with then
Lonnie the two of them were very akin to
brothers when Mary Jane Watson became
pregnant Peter Parker ultimately ended
up leaving and vacating the role now
what just does if this begins the
process of bringing in some of the
interim stories that took place between
the trial of Peter Parker and the
conclusion of spider-man clone Sawyer
now one of the reasons why we left some
of those stories out is just because of
the fact that discovers everything but
what Norman Osborn did is where Peter
said okay look Ben Riley according to
Seward trainer according to the
revelation that he gave us you are the
one who is the original i'ma clone
I'm taking my wife you know we smooth
things over after I'd you know slap you
across the face basically we're taking
off to Oregon and we are going to go
live a normal life you be spider-man he
are in New York now of course when that
happened fans were pissed I mean they
were so angry it was one of the craziest
things ever people were just so outraged
because they wanted Peter Parker to stay
it's the spider-man that going attach to
and in a lot of ways that makes sense
I remember spider-man has a heritage and
the realm of comic books he's the one
that really set the stage in a lot of
different ways the Teen Titans were his
predecessor to a degree but in terms of
the the the standing the spider-man
created the mark that he basically left
in the couple of a community it will
stand the test of time and remember if
ever since the 1940s there were no kids
superheroes and if you were kids
superhero you were a sidekick the Teen
Titans set the stage by saying we as
teenagers can have our own stories but
they were a team the spider-man was the
first time that we saw a successful
teenager on the main stage with his own
solo story spider-man really helped to
to empower a lot of teenage kids who sat
around wishing man I wish I could be a
superhero - and that's why Spiderman was
so significant and that's why he changed
so many things and so with Peter Parker
being moved out of the landscape all
that time that people had grown with his
character all those experiences that
they had all the times they'd seen him
struggle whether they had gotten in
during the night when Stacy died or went
afterwards when he had picked up in a
relationship with Mary Jane Watson they
were part and parcel to his life and
they didn't want to see that go away and
so because of that you know there was a
lot of backlash to the idea of Ben Riley
taking over the role but Marvel kept on
keeping on and so what we saw was that
with the exception of a couple of
instances when Peter Parker would appear
in the comics all the villains also see
all the stories of spider-man fighting
Mysterio and you know venom and carnage
and so on and so forth all that dealt
with Ben Riley now there was an event
that ended up bringing Peter Parker back
and this was basically Norman Osborn
grabbing the club for at least having
the smokestack torn down that resulted
in people discovering this corpse that
was wearing a spider-man outfit now
because of the fact that Ben Riley
himself didn't know about this because
Peter Parker didn't know about this
ultimately they ended up coming back
because remember and Peter Parker's mind
the body he threw down the smokestack
was gone that was Ben Riley but there
was never any reason for him to question
whatever happened to that body in the
smokestack he just kind of wondered well
I guess you know I guess then Riley
survived there's something I have no
idea and that was really yeah there
really wasn't a whole lot of exposition
or a whole lot of investigation that but
with this body being discovered that
she became okay where did this body come
from and what's going on and so it led
to Peter Parker and Mary Jane Watson
coming back the other half of this and
it's really one of the most tasteless
things that I've ever seen in comic
books was the idea of the child that
Peter Parker and Mary Jane Watson had
because of the fact that fans wanted to
see spider-man come back Marvel said
fine we'll give you Peter Parker but
it's going to come in a cost and so what
they did is they basically had the child
of Mary Jane Watson and Peter Parker
killed like it died it was it was
stillborn which that's not really
something that I agree with and it's not
something that I would bring up in this
video but it's probably a question
people are gonna have so I figured we
might as well answer it um not the best
decision that Marvel's made over the
course of their life those people who
know who Reef are enough back to
remember the Clone Saga look at that
moment maybe some of the other events in
Clone Saga in spider-man one more day
and say I don't understand I don't grasp
what it is what's going I don't that was
a really bad I was a really poor
decision on behalf of Marvel these
that's how they look at it anyway and
regardless of how it played out it
resulted in Peter Parker and Mary Mary
Jane Watson coming back to New York to
investigate everything that was going on
now with the return of Peter Parker
Norman Osborn effectively had to speed
up his own plans but something else that
I also want to talk about here is the
character of Kane and the reason why is
because of the fact that Kane had just
kind of been left out in no-man's land
following the events of the trial of
Peter Parker he was still a character he
was still in the stories but he didn't
nearly play the same kind of role that
he did before because all of his his
involvement everything that we had seen
about him being mysterious nobody really
knowing what he was all that basically
led up to the trial of Peter Parker when
he revealed himself to be the very first
clone after that it's like well what do
we do now you know where do we where do
we go from here and so what ended up
happening is Kane actually ended up
going back to the jackal miles Warren in
order to try to find a way to cure him
of his clone degeneration miles Warren
more or less scoffed at him laughed it
off at the same time the jackal
basically wanted to create like a giant
planet full of clones this led to a
massive conflict between spider-man and
man Ben Riley and Kane and the jackal
and so on and so forth but presumably
came it was believed to have been killed
he was thrown in a in a regeneration
tube eventually came back and then
handed himself over to the cops ah you
know for the cards that he had committed
and the things that he had done before
so it was away from Marvel just
kind of quickly dispensing them you say
okay fine whatever canes gone who cares
and that was it so by the time we got to
the conclusion of the Clone Saga we
basically end up picking up with just
Ben Riley and spider-man himself now
remember all these things with Norman
Osborn took place behind the scenes
Peter Parker Ben Riley none of these
guys had any idea that this was going on
they had no idea that Norman Osborn was
still alive that's what's really cool
here is the weight of this takes up this
you know last little tidbit we actually
end up having like Jay jonah Jameson and
Robbie Robertson the editor-in-chief of
The Daily Bugle they're all basically
brought to the Daily Bugle in this one
particular room for a meeting but the
crazy thing is that they've all received
invitations from different people and so
this was done directly by Norman Osborn
who basically revealed himself to be
alive to Peter Parker and the way this
ended up happening if he basically is
kind of seduced him by using some sort
of gas that basically permeates his body
and is designed specifically for Peter
just kind of a targeted gas but you know
keep some luzie and keeps them aware of
what's going on but ultimately no one
Osborn basically just reveals everything
that we just went over so we don't
really have to go over it again but this
is all brand new to Peter Parker that's
the crazy thing is because he has no
idea that any of this stuff happened he
had no idea what was taking place not
only that Norman Osborn demonstrates
that he had captured and defeated Ben
Riley now this is something that had
taken place in a different comic I
didn't really feel like it was necessary
to run over just because of the fact
that we could cover it here what did we
go through and do the comic play by
player discuss it it's still more or
less the same thing Ben Riley's
basically defeated and incapacitated by
the Green Goblin
and so what this was designed to do
anyway was lead to this great big huge
return of the Green Goblin himself not
only that then actually reveals to Peter
Parker that where Norman had basically
taunted him after defeating him saying
hey look I'm going to kill all the most
important members of Peter Parker's
family Ben Riley divulges his
information to Peter is of everybody
that you know you know Jay jonah Jameson
Robbie Robertson all the people that
you've met over the course of your life
who are significant to you or Green
Goblin is going to kill them all he's
going to kill every last one of them and
so what this does is it turns into a
race against Han it turns into Peter
Parker trying to get to the Green Goblin
as fast as he can and ultimately defeat
him now at this point it really turns
into kind of a cat-and-mouse game and
that's really the way it works when it
comes to the Green Goblin and you know
spider-man fighting it's always this
idea of your
Green Goblin chasing spider-man around
spider-man running away while he
formulates a plan turning the tables on
the Green Goblin it's really kind of a
hallmark of their characters or at least
you know when they first bought anyway
but the fact remains with Norman Osborn
the way intended to basically take down
all these different members of
spider-man's family more or less or the
people that he knows it's to literally
booby-trap the building and then just
destroy it in its entirety using these
different you know bonds that he's
creating so a goblin bomb so of course
Ben Riley is able to get them out but
again this continues to lead it to a
fight directly between Peter and Norman
Osborn now something to keep in mind
here is that this is not just like a
regular fight right like Peter Parker
look at the entire events of the Clone
Saga because while we didn't go over
every single thing you have to think
about it from a mind of Peter Peters
been told he's a clone on two occasions
he's come across two other clones of
himself Mary Jane Watson was pregnant he
was going to have a child that basically
ended up dying and then he finds out the
entirety of his life with regards to all
these clones has been manipulated by
Norman Osborn and on top of all of that
Aunt May passed away Peter Parker is
about as close to being as insane as
he's ever going to be totally losing his
BUN going against Norman Osborn with his
you know the the Goblin formula inside
of his own blood in a lot of ways allows
Peter to actually cut loose and that's
really what this is it's a chance for
Peter to basically just sort of cut
loose and take out all of his anger and
all of his wrath on Norman Osborn and
rightfully so that's one of the reasons
why this was kind of a big deal is
because of the fact but it's not like
Norman Osborn just happened to show up
at the wrong time and say I'm back and
Peter just lost his mind and attacking
Limonov or Norman is the source of all
the suffering that Peter Parker has
experienced in a lot of different ways
now keep in mind Norman's not
responsible for the death of onme he's
not responsible for the death of Peter
Parker's daughter he's an easy target
because he's basically screwed up
everything else and so again in the
midst of trying to kill Peter what he
actually does is try to kill him using
his own goblin glider only for Ben why
are we to jump in the way and to be
impaled by now this was Marvel sitting
down and saying okay look we tried we
tried to get rid of Peter Parker we
tried to eliminate him we try to replace
with Ben Reilly nobody wanted him there
you know the biggest problem that Marvel
faced though was that if they won't say
for example they left Ben Reilly a lot
somebody could have come along it's a
tall guess what guys were with at Clone
Saga well it turns out Ben Reilly was
the original the entire time it would
have just
open this massive Pandora's box of
things that people just didn't want to
come back anymore it would have just you
know we started this whole great big
huge era there people would rather just
kind of leave in the past that even
Marvel itself would rather leave in the
past and so because of this you know
with Norman Osborn basically being
responsible for the death of Ben Riley
it leads to this final conflict between
the two of them Norman Osborn is able to
make his escape you know he's able to
get away and the Green Goblin lives yet
again but Peter Parker is also able to
basically give Ben Riley the farewell DC
deserves but the way that Marvel came
along and said Ben Riley is definitively
the clone spider-man is definitively the
original is because of the fact that
when Ben Riley basically dies his body
breaks down and it just kind of
dissolved and the reason why that
matters is because of the fact that in
addition to Ben Riley and Kane there
were a whole host of other clones that
we didn't even talk about we didn't
really get their names or anything like
that they were for the most part
nameless and it was really a segment
whereby the jackal had like this this
army of clones chased down Ben Riley
over the course of the city all the
clones are basically defeated or they
were all killed off and then they just
more or less disintegrated but it was
marvelous stylish in the fact that this
is what happens to clones
whenever clones are defeated or whatever
they die their bodies just break down
and they just sort of dissolve and go
away and so this was essentially killing
off the character of Ben Riley saying
Ben Riley's gone and he's never going to
come back again or at least you know not
in this capacity so again that basically
into the Clone Saga is essentially all
just kind of called it a day
everything went away Peter Parker of
course goes back to Mary Jane Watson
you know after realizing that his
childhood essentially died and the two
of them grieved the best they can but
ultimately it creases kind of clean
break where it sets the stage for the
follow-up stories of Peter Parker absent
the Clone Saga
and dealing a little bit with the
aftermath but almost immediately
sweeping it all under the rug and moving
on to the next best thing but with that
being said guys we have finished this
Clone Saga I mean I we did the best of
what we had I think we did a pretty good
job hopefully you got the core of
everything and it all came together
pretty well and hopefully you guys
understand everything that's going on in
terms of the characters and the events
and you know the intricacies of you know
the important things anyway but if you
guys are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
please
you